we've talked about how you want your
learning algorithm to do well on the
training set but sometimes you don't
actually want to do too well and knowing
what human level performance is can tell
you exactly how well but not too well
you want your algorithm to do on the
training set let me show you what I mean
we've used classification a lot and
given a picture let's say humans have
near perfect accuracy so the human level
error is 1% in that case if your
learning algorithm achieves 8% training
error and 10% def error then maybe you
wanted to do better on the training set
so the fact that there's a huge gap
between how well your algorithm does on
your training set versus how well humans
do shows that your algorithm isn't even
fitting the training set well so in
terms of tools to reduce bias or
variance in this case I would say focus
on reducing bias so you want to do
things like find a training bigger
neural network or run gradient descent
longer just try to do better on the
training set but now let's look at the
same training erin jeff error and
imagine that human level performance was
not 1 percent so miscopied is over but
you know in a different application or
maybe on a different data set let's say
that human level error is actually 7.5
percent maybe the images in your data
set are so very that even humans can
tell whether there's a cat in this
picture this is a this example is maybe
slightly contrived because humans
actually very good at looking at
pictures and telling there's a cat in it
or not but for the sake of this example
let's say your data sets images are so
very or so low resolution that given
humans get 7.5 percent error in this
case even though you're trading error in
dev there are the same as the other
example you see that maybe actually
doing just fine on the training set
doing only a little bit worse than human
level performance and in this second
example you would maybe want to focus on
reducing this components reducing
um
the variance in your learning algorithm
so you might try regularization to try
to bring your def error closer to your
training error for example so in the
earlier courses discussion on bias and
variance we were mainly assuming that
they were tasks where Bayes error is
nearly zero so to explain what just
happened here for our CAD classification
example think of human level error as a
proxy or as an estimate for Bayes error
alpha Bayes optimal error and for
computer vision tasks this is a pretty
reasonable proxy because humans are
actually very good at computer vision
and so whatever a human can do is maybe
not too far from Bayes error by
definition human level error is worse
than Bayes error because nothing can be
better than Bayes error but human level
error might not be too far from these
error so the surprising thing you saw
here is that depending on what human
level error is or really this is really
uh approximately Bayes error also we
assumed it to be but depending on what
we think is achievable with the same
training error and death error in these
two cases we decided to focus on bias
reduction tactics or on variance
reduction techniques and what happened
is in the example on the Left eight
percent training error is really high
when you think you could get it down to
one percent and so bias reduction
technique could help you do that
whereas in the example on the right if
you think that Bayes error is 7.5
percent and share we're using human
level error as an estimate or as a proxy
for Bayes error do you think that Bayes
error is close to 7.5% and you know
there's not that much Headroom for
reducing your training error further
down you don't really want it to be that
much better than 7.5% because you can
achieve that only by maybe song need to
over fit the training
and instead there's much more room for
improvement in terms of taking this 2%
gap and trying to reduce that by using
variance reduction techniques such as
regularization or maybe getting more
training data so to give these things a
couple names this is not widely used
terminology but I found this useful -
margin useful way of thinking about it
which is I'm going to call the
difference between Bayes error or
approximation of Bayes error and the
training error to be the avoidable bias
so what you want is to maybe keep
improving your training performance
until you get down to Bayes error but
you don't actually want to do better
than a zero you can't actually do better
than Bayes error unless you're
overfitting and this the difference
between your training error and def
error that's a measure still of the
variance problem of your algorithm and
the term avoidable bias acknowledges
that there's some bias or some minimum
level of error that you just cannot get
below which is that if Bayes error 7.5
percent you don't actually want to get
below that level of error so rather than
saying that if your training error is 8
percent then to 8 percent is a measure
Advisors in this example you're saying
that the avoidable bias is maybe 0.5% or
0.5% is a measure of the avoidable bias
whereas 2 percent is a measure of the
variance and so there's much more room
in reducing this to percents than in
reducing to 0.5 percent whereas in
contrast in the example on the left this
7 percent is a measure of the avoidable
buyers whereas 2 percent is a measure of
how much variance you have and so in
this example on the Left there's much
more potential in focusing on reducing
bands of avoidable bias so in this
example understanding human level error
understanding your estimate of Bayes are
already causes you in different
scenarios to go
on different tactics with a bias
avoidance tactic reverance avoidance
tactics there's quite a lot more nuance
how you factor in human level
performance into how you make decisions
in choosing what to focus on less in the
next video go deeper into understanding
of what human level performance really
means